imagine getting 100 new subscribers
every single day that's around 3,000
subscribers per month and in this
episode of the think media podcast I'm
going to be breaking down 10 tactical
tips to help you achieve just that I'm
also going to be covering some outdated
tactics that frankly don't work any
longer and are a waste of your time and
your energy so let's dive into it but
first we need to address a mistake that
a lot of creat make and that is only
focusing on views and not focusing on
their subscriber rate and so a
subscriber rate is basically this if
your channel got 100,000 views in a
month and you had a subscriber rate of
3% then that means you would have grown
3,000 new subscribers or roughly 100 new
subscribers per day on average that
month and 3% is pretty amazing like most
channels probably have a 1 perc or even
a fraction of a percent subscriber rate
but what this reveals to us is that
views is not the only thing we should be
focusing on our goal should also be to
increase the rate with which people
connect with us hit the Subscribe button
because we're being intentional in the
content we're crafting with these 10
tips which brings us to tip number one
upload consistently now I know what
you're thinking it's one of the most
commonly shared YouTube tips that you've
probably heard before but I believe it's
the foundation of getting 100
subscribers per day consistency is what
transforms average into excellence and
YouTube is a place where momentum builds
over time for example my think media
podcast Channel now gets well over 100
subscribers per day but it didn't start
that way it started with committing to
posting one upload per week and during
2020 I was getting around Seven Subs per
day up to maybe 150 on a good day last
month which is 4 years later I'm now
averaging around 2 new subscribers to
the channel per day and it's not just
the consistency that's happened over the
last few years but frequency is also
increased I'm now doing two long form
podcasts a week two clips a week two to
four shorts live streams two to four
times a month and so if you want to
build momentum getting to 100
subscribers a day set a baseline for
consistency to start commit to things
for the Long Haul but recognize that
there's a flywheel effect on YouTube
where subscriber growth will grow as
your library of quality content grows
number two is write clickable titles one
of the common mistakes I see on creators
that I'm coaching when I do Channel
reviews and looking at their content is
their titles are either terrible or
maybe they're okay like they're clear
but they lack a punch to them they lack
a curiosity to them they don't make me
want to click and in 2024 there's kind
of no excuse for this with tools like
Bard and chat gbt and vid IQ powering up
your titles has never been easier when
optimizing for search engines you're
thinking about keyword research and
topic research and making sure that the
big idea and the actual Search terms are
included in your title but even more
importantly is then the humanization of
that title how readable is it like is it
a fifth grade reading level and is it
read smoothly does it read clearly how
much curiosity does the title create how
interesting is the title is the big idea
clear in the video by powering up your
titles across your library of videos you
will increase your click-through rate
Therefore your viewership giving you
more opportunity for 100 subscribers a
day and by increasing your clickthrough
rate and getting more people to watch
your videos you now have an opportunity
to invite them to subscribe which brings
us to number three give people a clear
features and benefits reason to
subscribe here's the business definition
of features and benefits a feature is
the essential function or component of a
good or a service in contrast a benefit
refers to how a product's features could
make a consumer's life easier and more
enjoyable and for example the feature of
a car could be air conditioning but the
articulation of the benefit is that
you're going to be comfortable you're
going to be cool your passengers are
going to be more comfortable and cool
you're not going to be overheated when
it's super hot outside and the mistake
creators make is they don't articulate
both when they're pitching the value of
their YouTube channel for example this
YouTube channel in this video podcast is
all about unfiltered YouTube tips for
helping you build a profitable channnel
let's break that down the features are
that you're going to get YouTube tips
now you might be able to fill in the
blank and say there's a reason why you
want those but do you ultimately want
YouTube tips when you wake up every
morning or do you want the result that
the YouTube tips will bring you so the
benefits become yes I can help you get
more views and make money and even more
than that the benefits could become so
you can build a YouTube channel you're
proud of so that you ultimately have
more satisfaction make an impact in the
world and so it's both how could you
include things when you're pitching the
value of your channel like I'm going to
teach you this and share this feature
and this practical thing that will save
you time that is for busy moms the
benefit is your understanding of how it
actually makes people's life easier and
more enjoyable this is also an
opportunity for you to articulate at the
unique difference of your channel like
maybe your content is more
familyfriendly or maybe it's more
unhinged and full of profanity that is
ultimately a difference like the
features of a lot of YouTube channels
are going to be the same but the
benefits or the angle with which you
create your content can really resonate
with certain people that are going to
hit that subscribe button so you want to
make sure you're giving clear features
and benefits reasons to subscribe to
your channel that would be articulated
in the video at some point but the other
opportunity is visual call to actions
which are a lot simpler it might just be
a subscribe button that pops up on
screen maybe you don't say anything a
little click noise or no noise at all
that kind of reminds people to subscribe
the key Point here is that if we're
going to increase our subscriber rate we
want to make sure we're actually
inviting people to subscribe to the
channel number four high value
non-spammy comments on bigger channels
if you're looking to increase the
awareness of your channel you're just
getting started you're wanting to build
up that momentum of people discovering
you one of the ways to do that is to
comment on bigger channels that have a
lot of conversation happening in the
comments section think about your own
behavior many people while they're
watching a video immediately scroll down
letting the video autoplay and listening
to it and start looking at what people
are saying if comments get a lot of
Thumbs Up hence high value non-spammy
comments that have something edifying
something valuable to say then there
could be a lot of awareness of that
person's channel on a video that's
getting tens of thousands or even
millions of views and so two tips here
is you want to comment early because the
sooner you comment on the video the more
opportunity the lifetime viewership of
the video people can keep thumbs uping
and keep seeing your comment but I think
the way to do this right is to do it in
a non-spammy way that really actually
adds viewer to the Creator and to the
conversation happening around that video
and if you think about the other viewer
seeing your comment the tips you share
the perspective you share the context
you share can create curiosity in them
to click through on your channel and
ultimately check out what you're doing
number five improve your content now
you're probably thinking Sean this is
one of those Captain Obvious tips like I
know I need to make better content and
make better videos and I actually have a
practical tip for you in just a second
but remember this is also what our
entire company and this whole podcast is
about so definitely subscribe because we
have some incredible videos coming out
this year and podcast episodes to help
you continuously improve your content
but here's one practical tip each video
should have a promise and a payoff your
titles should make a promise and then
the video should be the payoff let's put
ourselves in the viewers shoes they're
searching YouTube or videos are being
recommended to them and every time they
see a title and a thumbnail there's
essentially a promise there like it's an
open door to say say okay you're
promising me education or entertainment
so they click on the video and what do
they want next they want a payoff the
question is how much patience do they
have until they get the payoff of what
you promised and YouTube is really a
transaction in the sense of if they
click on your video and get an
experience with your video your brand
and a payoff follows a connection was
made the opposite is true that if you
promis something in your title and don't
deliver it in your video or you take too
long to get there then the viewer jumps
off or they feel like man you eventually
got there but they're kind of frustrated
with the transaction now the reason this
is powerful is because ultimately it
triggers dopamine see dopamine acts on
areas of the brain to give you feelings
of pleasure satisfaction and motivation
and so when someone clicks on a YouTube
video there's hope that there's going to
be a payoff your job when it comes to
improving your videos is making sure
that they get that payoff hopefully
multiple payoffs by light bul moments
laughter entertainment moments and I
think just you being more thoughtful on
your next video about architecting this
again will help you get more views and
get to 100 subscribers a day faster now
before we get into number six I just
want to give you a quick heads up that
if you've been on the fence about
joining us in our online course called
video ranking Academy we have a special
offer happening right now that's ending
soon if you want to check that out it's
at VR podcast.com we only do this a
couple times a year right around the
time that we do our YouTube challenges
and one of those just ended so to see
all the details hit the link in the show
notes or just go to V podcast.com but
let's get into number six number six is
collaborate with other creators which if
Done Right is a great way to increase
your subscribers and get awareness from
new audiences now I have a warning for
you one of the biggest mistakes I
creators make is they think that all
subscribers are equal and they would
take any opportunity to collaborate with
somebody that's influential and that
could help them get new subscribers the
problem is you don't want just any
subscribers you want subscribers that
are aligned with your content and that
will keep watching future videos so you
want to be selective with who you
collaborate with and one of the cool
things is that collaborations are easier
than they've ever been before you can
use online tools like streamyard and
like Dropbox to exchange footage to swap
footage you can collaborate with digital
tools and writing scripts and planning
out the video and so a collaboration
might be actually building out a YouTube
video where one goes on your channel and
the part two goes on the other person's
Channel and then you cross promote using
the YouTube end card and you do that
really intelligently the other thing to
do is simply interviews an interview is
probably the simplest way to collab and
again digital interviews are easier than
ever before so no matter where you're
based in the world it's possible to do
this but I know you might have a few
objections like why would anyone want to
collaborate with a smaller Channel or
how could I get a super famous YouTuber
to collaborate with me and my thoughts
are this one it's smart to collaborate
with creators at your same level like
maybe you have a few hundred subscribers
it would be practical to find some
Synergy with a creator that has a few
thousand but probably not millions of
subscribers kind of staying in your same
sphere of influence
but two don't make the mistake of
thinking that influence is the only
metric by which somebody would want to
collaborate with you ultimately what it
is is a value exchange and so if you can
articulate what value you could provide
which might just be clear in the style
of content you create maybe there's some
Synergy around your skills in video
editing storytelling content creation
maybe the access to resources or
locations or cool experiences that you
have or cool IDE ideas and put yourself
in the shoes of the person that you want
to collaborate with you know content
creation is hard and so if you bring the
heavy lifting to the table maybe with
the scripting and the filming or the big
idea or the research they might be like
that sounds really cool I appreciate you
doing all of that heavy lifting and so
you're bringing all of that to the table
maybe they're bringing a little bit more
influence to the table and boom you've
got some Synergy and a value exchange
practically you can find these
collaborations by reaching out and
connecting with these different creators
on social media being engaged in their
communities and comments and tapping
into the power of in-person events to
actually meet face to face and see what
kind of synergy you can create with
others number seven focus on Evergreen
content here's the truth one video can
bring you new subscribers every day for
years to come for example on my think
media podcast Channel there's a video
about the seven most profitable niches
on YouTube it's actually a clip from a
fulllength podcast but here's what's
crazy this video generated 158 new
subscribers over the past month but the
video is 8 months old now imagine if you
had 30 or so videos generating you 150
subscribers every month then now you've
crossed that 100 subscribers everyday
threshold so rather than just getting
subscribers when you upload new videos
my goal is to build a library of ranked
videos a library of Evergreen content
that generates subscribers every single
day number eight share your content in
relevant communities this could be
Reddit Discord Facebook groups and
things like that but remember you don't
want to do this in a spammy and just
self-promotional way you want to do this
in a way that adds value to that
community and creates curios I it and
interest in your content which can
absolutely lead to lots of new
subscribers it reminds me of one of our
video ranking Academy students who has a
Channel about plant-based cooking and
vegan recipes and what they did was they
began to look around for different
groups of passionate plant-based
enthusiasts they found a Facebook group
that was all about that topic they
joined that Community started engaging
in that community and at one point
created a post post about a particular
recipe that they did they didn't just
say go check out my channel go subscribe
to my channel but they actually wrote a
couple paragraphs of what the video was
about how good the recipe was what their
experience was with it and the post blew
up it got likes it got comments and as a
result people click through over to
YouTube and the video blew up and I'll
never forget seeing the growth results
over the next 30 days her Channel grew
by
16,000 per. thousands of subscribers
tens of thousands of views all because
of sharing the video in a group in an
authentic way number nine rank your
videos in YouTube search and YouTube
suggested so what exactly is a ranked
video well ranked video is a video that
appears in the top search results when
you type in a search query on YouTube
it's in the top results or it's on the
first page or it's a video that is
continually suggested by the YouTube
algorithm showing up on people's
homepages being recommended alongside of
other videos our definition of A ranked
video here at think media is simply a
video that you post once but continues
to get views for weeks months and even
years to come and of course if the goal
is to grow your following every single
day the more ranked videos you have the
more consistent your channel growth will
be whether or not you post new videos
for example one of our video ranking
Academy students Jen has a channel for
busy moms one of the videos she posted
last year was Mega budget meals 3 hours
of delicious Cheap Eats with 45 extreme
budget recipes now fast forward five
months and this video still gets
134 views per hour every single day vph
is an important term to know it's views
per hour and if you can keep getting
views on a video that is 5 months old
imagine whatever your subscriber rate is
that video will keep attracting new
subscribers to your channel another one
of our students Andrew finny is a Las
Vegas real estate agent who posted a
video four years ago on how a home
equity line of credit Works hilock
explained and how to get a HELOC now
that video today four years later is
still getting 10 point .4 views per hour
every single day just imagine having one
or two or 10 or 100 ranked videos on
your channel I believe that this is one
of the fundamental keys to getting 100
new subscribers every single day the
more ranked videos in your library the
more consistent your views and channel
growth will be which brings us to our
final tip for getting 100 new
subscribers every single day on YouTube
and it's this number 10 don't quit the
truth is 100 new subscribers every day
is an incredible feat it's going to take
determination grit resilience patience
skill building and so there's something
about committing to the journey I've
learned that commitment is the
foundation of all Great accomplishments
and great things take time and great
things take patience and when I think
about the power of commitment and not
quitting it makes me reflect on this
very podcast the think media podcast you
know this was launched back in 2020 and
if you look at the views they are kind
of flat now I was getting views but
there was no spikes to them in 2021
there's maybe a little bit of momentum
2022 got pretty crazy and last year 2023
it was insane just want to encourage you
that's a 4year journey see too many
creators are judging their results by
the past four weeks and underestimating
the power of committing to building your
YouTube channel over four years and if
you know me you might say Sean your
thick media podcast growth is still
insane even in four years and you had
think media already and you even had a
decade of experience before that and
you're right even with all of that
experience and shouting out the podcast
channel from the other channel it still
took a few years to build Crazy momentum
with our podcast channel the powerful
thing about YouTube is that if you
create content strategically and if you
rank videos YouTube is like a fine wine
your content gets better with age and
you will start getting more subscribers
week after week and year after year
especially when you apply these tips
rank your videos allocate some of your
energy towards Evergreen content and
continually improve and level up on your
next upload and if you've been enjoying
the think media podcast content and you
know that this year you really want to
stop dabbling and start dominating on
YouTube and get really serious about
your YouTube channel then I do want to
invite you to check out VR podcast.com
where you can actually see the best way
we can help you at think media go faster
get more subscribers and really Master
the necessary skill set for creating a
profitable YouTube channel right now we
have a special offer going on that only
happens a couple times a year and that
link is in the show note below my name
is Sean canel rhymes with YouTube
channel this is the think media podcast
if you got value today would love to
hear your feedback in the YouTube
comments or like rate and review
wherever you listen to podcasts and I
can't wait to connect with you in a
future episode